[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone welcome to awesome comics
your one-stop shop for everything comic
book entertainments related I'm your
host Heather roof today only a second
time I've ever been in the chair yeah
I'm super pumped to be here I've got
some great people to discuss it with me
including rogue oh hello
that's Ayanna Wade for those of you who
are now just tuning in to our show
welcome hello and welcome back to all
everyone yeah yeah and over here Brian
Porter would be your new next Wolverine
after Hugh Jackman and it works because
I'm actually a short as Wolverine people
have a cheating childhood dream say
hello um hmm yeah
Oh Anakin's you couldn't figure it out
based on rogue and wolverine over here
what are we talking we are talking about
the 1990s x-men animated TV series our
top ten episodes coming at you right now
but before we get to it don't forget go
to our Facebook page facebook.com slash
awesome comics show give that a like we
put up a whole bunch of exclusive videos
every week sometimes to some content up
there that's exclusive to the page so
check it out this is yeah sometimes
there's too much to talk about here so
we do extra stuff after the show you get
a little behind-the-scenes yes exactly
that you all love sources laughs oh good
check it out laughs all right so let's
jump right into it our first episode
number 10
[Music]
nights of the Sentinels season 1 this is
the first episodes of the show so it
started off strong although I believe I
thought I was reading trivia somewhere
that the first episode actually wasn't
completely finished when it aired like
some of the scenes that they they added
in reruns weren't exactly finished the
first time it aired um but we're
introduced in these episodes to Jubilee
whose parents are who have registered as
her as a mutant for the official mutant
registry list which turns out to be a
kidnapping scheme the Sentinels
attempts to kidnap her but she is saved
by storm and rogue she goes back to her
apparently damaged
oh the right gosh and right about that
epic mole fight but she's no good for
self kidnaps because she's a teenager
yeah man rolling she's like pretty much
always good for kidnapping no all the
whole series it wouldn't get kidnapped
it's nice uh you believe yes yeah yeah
that's true it's true so eventually the
x-men destroy all the data in the mutant
registry system it's pretty cool fight
nothing else with the Sentinels beast in
his eloquent destroying of it and storms
like I don't have time for this
bolt I don't know the bed story I'm
growing up with my favorite because of
the series she is just amazing it like
calm headed and just will be like ya
know that's what we're doing let's do it
until you put her in the book right oh
man claustrophobia yeah it's rough
number nine cold comfort
season three one of the reasons I love
this episode is the ice man comes into
it and a lot of people would we'll admit
it's super fan services a lot of people
are like oh this episode isn't that
great but it's full of so many things if
you read the x-men comics like ice mens
in there the x-factor team is brought in
there for a little while but one of the
reasons I really love it is some of the
relationship that they showcase between
Bobby and exams
they have like this father-son type of
relationship and you get to see how it
all went bad yeah so it's interesting to
see xavier take on instead of a
perfecter role leiria father in your
role which is very different I wish they
would have had more of Bobby in the
series
yes that would've been cool I liked how
they brought him in later other series
like early 2000s or whatever but it
wasn't like that more of them and you
know the ex my period would have been
would have been nice
Thanks he's a cool character yes he is
so and I think that you talk about the
point where like it's fanservice
whatever I think a lot of the most
memorable episodes at least for me and I
think a lot of other people were the
ones that were like just answer which is
really awesome not great content
episodes like a story didn't blow you
away but it's just like you'd see these
characters for the first time on like
you know animated screen or whatever I
just like a lot of those a lot of my
favorites were ones that were just like
regular stories but I got to see certain
characters or whatever right right it
paid off you read the comics number
eight long shot from season five
basically long shot is transported from
wherever mojo transmits his stuff in the
galaxy to earth and mojo comes to
collect his star attraction and I really
like this episode because we could see
more of mojo he's one of my all-time
favorite like villains in the whole
series he's I think he's one of the best
written like character villains because
his dialogue it's so fast and ridiculous
and it doesn't feel stilted or bored
like some of the other villains or just
very I'm a bad guy and I'm going to do
this and it's that because I'm bad but
no mojo just had like all this like this
energy and personality and I wish that
we only got like I think two episodes of
him and I thought that he was just an
awesome character I loved any time he
was on screen and then just him coming
to earth and then his presence you know
taking away all the life force all that
was really good and then
you know beast and rogue and Wolverine
Jubilee are there they sent out he sends
out a purple mechanical dinosaur and his
one lieutenants like purple dinosaurs I
trust me the kids will love it I'm like
yes it is amazing it's kind of lameta
how he's obsessed with everything being
televised being the best in the universe
yeah at that kind of a thing and I
thought it was just he was a really good
character and I would love to see more
of him but like mojo is one of the
characters I remember from seeing it in
the early 90s and you know I was like
pretty young at the time but I still
remember first time seeing it all the
way till now 24th years mojo was always
always there Styx looking yeah
definitely and then he's like kind of
terrifying looking like with the way
that his face in the big ass like kind
of Joker smile a little bit and just in
your face in the camera shot like really
really close up I thought it was just
like a really creepy character too and
for a kid shows like that's kind of like
a lot and add that thought was really
awesome but it was a really good episode
gets the longshot beat some ass a little
a little bit of a like a love story ish
with what's-her-name to believably
handwash and is really good Wolverine
hating that like it's like a big brother
old arena yeah yeah oh it's cute I like
any of those moments in the Wolverine I
guess be like nope nope that's my number
7 a rope tail season 2 yet see more of
rogues past in depth and kind of her
relationship with mystique a little bit
more of that information because
spoilers - mom I totally forgot about
that and I thought that was like really
awesome I'm like oh wow that's right
I'm speak and then later on and we find
out about a Nightcrawler we also kind of
get to figure out why rogue will have
some of the powers that she has and
right because she stole them he was told
to steal them and didn't understand why
but yet took them from this Marvel right
oh my gosh I love that yeah I love that
that way
like heartbreaking marvels amazing and
then you kind of see this like coma
patients and we get a little more
backstory into oh yeah no that's because
it's broke-broke put her into this like
comatose state right let it go and then
the episode ends so sweet bro goes to
visit her and they're like Oh consider
for our Chango we never see her just
like her name's Carol Danvers she's a
friend that man that's really cool like
taken in from like you know the like war
of the comics or whatever and it's like
it's a good character with a deep pass
and they just kind of pluck that in
there put in there it's just like wow
that they they showed the depths that
they can go with the comics and the
writing mm-hmm and especially in the
later seasons I feel like the depth of
the writing was really good and they
took a lot of time to flesh out these
stories and even though there was a
one-off story it's like they really
fleshed out that out in 20 minutes I'm
really good yeah yeah well one of my
favorite things about that episode is
the mind battle yes because actually
showed the struggle when rogue absorbed
Miss Marvel she also absorbed part of
her and her personality so there's a the
episode begins with a struggle in her
mind between her and Miss Marvel rogue
and Miss Marvel and then it ends with
this epic fight in sight of her mind yet
with gene involved too yeah so cool this
is already this is later when she's
already had like times when she's
touched people and accidentally like
accidentally touched people I'm not
meaning to take their power so to see
like when she purposely technically did
it that was really cool the struggle so
real number six slave island season one
because I see gambit Jubilee and storm
get to go on a vacation
yeah they research but yeah so make
island yeah they go to Island but
basically not expecting it to be
anything bad and then oh yeah note your
slaves and they get collared but on a
local episode in this show when they get
like those like power taken away collars
straining yeah very frustrating yeah
and storm is amazing in this episode
she's moving every step specifically
this episode because I was talked about
earlier she's just so level-headed and
just always tends to like take care of
people and in this one she gets put in a
box and she has bought cheese cloth
robic and so it's really interesting to
see her at a moment of vulnerability
which is kind of really interesting and
the fact that she's still even though
she's vulnerable and and she's still
fighting back then yeah it reminds me
one of the other episodes where a bunch
of rebel falls on top of her and Scott's
like oh god get storm out she's
claustrophobic and I was like that's
what you're focusing on that not the
tons of rubble that just drops on your
friends yeah might be dead no each
claustrophobic we are out of these rocks
well he knew she survived that yeah this
road
she's about it knows about it I also
like gambit we're not really sure if his
motives in this one - yeah it kind of
seems like she's turning on the team
basically though I really like kind of
that as if you are you're like oh
there's like an overall themes
throughout gambit and throughout series
like there's a lot of times well we
don't know your past and it's an area
it's always very ambiguous on its past
or whatever and like there's never a
full trust with him but almost of the
series I think you know later on they
finally do but it's like there's always
that little in the back of your mind
like is he gonna again screw us over and
this one specifically we see him doing
things that would lead you to believe
that he is definitely turning on them
too so even more evidence as being like
great but if here for us and why are you
telling this stuff is not helping us
break out and stuff so right yeah one of
the first episodes of that is kind of
explored yeah which is really class
number five Days of Future past season
one that's those 11 and 12 system
partners basically Bishop travels back
in time after meeting an older Wolverine
stop an assassination that will save
this future from becoming ruled by
sentinels Bishop thinks that it's gambit
turns out to be mystique the
assassination is foiled but things are
still not right in Bishop's future I
really like this episode because it's
one of their like more known story lines
and the to see that on screen was really
cool and it's interested in the ways
that they took about it and all that and
like seeing the dystopian future and
then seeing that Wolverine even though
it's like they're in what was like
twenty fifty five or something like that
ya know it's really far in the future
and Wolverine still a badass got a
little bit of gray a couple more lines
but it's like okay he's still going to
be there you know leading the rebellion
all that stuff and seeing Bishop was
always really cool without I think he's
a really good character and just setting
up who he is and where he comes from all
I thought that was great but uh there's
some some things in that episode that I
was kind of like really the automatic
memory no memory it's like you mention
that at all and the possibility of time
travel you might not remember any of it
but I really liked all you know oh
gambits you know I'm gonna beat the hell
out of them and then you know Wolverine
kind of sides with them like what we
don't know a lot about your past this
and that and then gambit leaves and like
man this is really good and it being
mystique it's like I totally forgot was
that and I was like why did Cabot now as
he's there yeah is the blob yeah such a
funny character is like ridiculous yeah
and then what was the I can never
remember the guy that does to the light
that quake stuff oh I can't ever
remember the man that guy but he that
guy was in it and it's just it was
really funny and too many names and
nobody exponentially it's my building
these like multi or so
yeah yeah there's oh my gosh they just
throw the character that you really cool
but also we were talking about your like
looks like again definitely when you're
on your children you know why I don't
like I don't know who has these people
are but they're cool they're just like
yeah she does stuff yeah I like still
make in her arms of idiot yeah but uh
yeah it was a really was a good episode
it was a funny episode and it set up the
whole thing with rogue and mystique like
you know changes into her mother and
ropes like oh my god Wow yeah you know
she like kind of takes her away and you
know see her I don't see it as like a
full betrayal or anything like that
excellent but it's still like world
doing something that she normally
wouldn't do even though its mystique he
knows its mystique but it's also her mom
right and it just shows how the you know
the ties the family can alter how you do
stuff that you normally do and I thought
it was just a really good episode and
just you know watching Bishop battle and
his awesome gun and it was really good
and his huge size I'm seeing on nomads
comeback is really cool yeah upgrade and
sent an old type thing I think that's
pretty awesome
I mean time tales travel in general is
always awesome
no synonymous with dragon side yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then we got to see Forge I
really like seeing Forge that was really
cool and then bitch'll comes back and
it's like wow everything's still messed
up what I love that and it's really good
so it was one of the more memorable
episode special because it is David's
future past we ended up getting a movie
out of it which was different just a
belief that well yeah I may be out of it
that is the middlee happened that's the
thing is we have not given
number four repo-man
season two Wolverines backstory is
explored he's loaded alert back to
Canada by his old team Elsa flight they
wanted him to join backup but he's
really taken back to the lab where
experiments are run on him to examine
his skeleton which is fused with
adamantium the team comes to his aid
when they realized that he is being used
as a lab rat and it's a any episode we
get to delve into Wolverines backstory
is awesome and the fact that we get to
see also flight and this is really cool
you know the Canadian like the Canadian
x-men basically right right they've got
some really cool characters and I liked
in the comics like especially an
alternate theory ultimate x-men series
there's a lot to do with Wolverine and
Alpha Flight and I just thought they're
really cool characters yeah and any time
they go into like talking about
Wolverines adamantium skeleton and what
it can actually do is really awesome
he's like I feel like in the episodes
they don't really talk about it too much
it's just kind of known but then it's
like this is like pretty interesting and
it has he had some pretty awesome not
powers but abilities thanks to his
adamantium skeleton you know I want to
make some heavier but too it makes them
a lot stronger and he's a pretty strong
mutants and compared to a lot of his
teammates and I just think anytime we go
into his backstory it's like yes
more will remain let's do it and it just
reminds me of the Wolverine Origins yeah
comics which I love so little design of
getting that adamantium in him it was
like yeah strips and then it raised him
and then just absorbed into it or
whatever and that was interesting right
yeah right I mean one of the strongest
things about the series in general this
animated series is how character driven
it is yeah so easy if you're doing a kid
show to just be like well whatever the
kids don't go with Wolverines like let's
just keep going but this series really
focused on the character so anytime we
get a character driven episode it's
always something that you we enjoy
[Music]
number three till death do us part
season two and this begins with the epic
wedding of Scott and Gina and they're
married or so we think I love the bit
too when we see Wolverine fighting and
we think that he's like we assume since
he's wearing like a suit and everything
that he's against the marriage is what I
had been watching it growing up yeah and
it was it was really interesting and we
see it's like one of those like AI robot
II like mom I think you gotta yeah yeah
but the episode focuses on morph who
comes back from the dead they think that
he was dead at one but he comes back
kind of messes with the x-men since he
can morph into anyone and it's really
interesting to see how they react to
that and then react to each other what
they think is playing whoo and
everything who you gonna trust right
right exactly playing on all those
weaknesses that he knows because he used
to be a part of the team so that's a
great episode as well
[Music]
number two time fugitive season two and
this is another episode with Bishop so
as we mentioned last time his future is
all my stuff at the time messed up with
a plague so we've got to come back try
to figure out how we can cure the plague
but at the same time we have someone
else oh gosh cable thanks
we have cable coming back as well
because he doesn't want his future
destroyed right so it's a whole thing
with Bishop future than cable future and
they eventually come together to figure
out that the plague started in this
basement lab with apocalypse and they
find a cure for the disease by infecting
Wolverine it's all cables idea he
decides to infect Wolverine with the
disease and she's a healer
it creates antibodies and then boom the
plague is fixed and apocalypse no longer
rules cable future yeah cable you know
time-traveling mutant bishop time tree
we mutants stem two together so much
time traveling paradox Katie oh my god
for dick but I really like seeing those
two together and cable with a badass
I love cable and just seeing those two
time-traveling powerhouses like go at it
is really cool but I always thought it
was like why don't they just stay their
future suck ass well they like cable as
the Sun well so yeah they have things
that keep them in their future you know
and that also doesn't change the fact of
the futures they're going to suck for
someone else that's the great selfish
corner I mean this is Molly didn't throw
it under this kick and I think our life
second or third time yeah my future
still suck let's go to the ninth hour
Laurie days 190 everything got fixed
anyway so it doesn't even matter
number one the Phoenix saga why
obviously Jean Grey becomes Phoenix I
don't know even how does that oh my
little five-part series or about the
Phoenix saga it's like there are these
little side stories in each episode
debate well today I will say this is the
episode that I remember the most growing
up yeah we watching it I remembered a
specific episode Schaffer shot and I was
like racking my brain why do I remember
this so well why do I remember this well
and sure no logs on the go oh wish but
not know who I am I'm the bigger object
and then I realized I remembered it when
it would be like one of those original
videos on the internet of oh man wish
they ended up putting in the movie
through the right the live-action so I
appreciate that but yeah Phoenix saga
check it out bitch we know what five
episodes technically but it's a
fantastic story arc and it definitely I
mean it flows like one episode yeah
there's no like time jumps or anything
it just keeps on going right perfectly
sequential just watch it all all of it
too bad that's it that's our choice
Jesus little side stories with some
banshee and brother and then professor
X's side coming out also
that was really cool and it was really
interesting that based on how much
people trust him that he was still being
questioned as to whether like what was
happening was reality or not that he was
seeing so that was really anything - and
seeing the struggle I was like okay we
trust you but also we're going to send
you over to Muir Island right take a
breather
chill out he'll be fine I also like that
uh when he was like messing with x-men
you get to see a little bit of Deadpool
yes second raha Midori yes yeah I got a
minute just another so those are our top
10 episodes guys let us know if there's
any that you think that we missed in the
comments let us know what your favorites
are in the comments really quickly you
can find me on twitter at how the roots
working people flying to you Ayana wait
i am on it facebook at facebook.com
slash ayan away easy to remember also
Twitter and Instagram and snapchat
wonderful Porter I'm not on nearly as
much facebook.com slash awesome Porter
and I do have a Twitter in case you
didn't know that it's porkchop's
zero two eight nine all right awesome
again the cure check out Facebook comp
less awesome comics show um probably
have some extra episodes up there on
Thursdays to let you know something
going on so thanks for watching and we
will see you guys on the next day
[Music]
[Applause]
you